>> IT WAS A COUNTRY IN CHAOS.
>> BOMB THREAT.
>> JEWISH COMMUNITY CENTER.
>> ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> HATE CRIME.
>> A NATION DIVIDED.
>> THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY NO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> MASS DEPORTATION.
>> LED BY A PRESIDENT WITH
UNCHECKED POWER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST SPOKE TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> TAX RETURNS FROM DONALD
TRUMP --
>> REPUBLICANS HAVE BLOCKED THE
FIRST ATTEMPT.
>> THEY GOT TO GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER.
>> UNTIL ONE REPUBLICAN DECIDED
ENOUGH WAS ENOUGH.
A PATRIOT WHO PUT COUNTRY OVER
PARTY.
WHO FINALLY STOOD UP FOR HIS
NATION'S FOUNDING VALUES.
A MAN BY THE NAME OF -- TBD.
>> [ INAUDIBLE ] OF THE
ELECTIONS.
HE CARED ABOUT WHAT WAS RIGHT.
>> DO YOU WANT TO SPEAK OUT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT?
AREN'T YOU SCARED?
>> BRAVE RESPONSE, TBD.
>> BRAVE RESPONSE.
>> CONSERVATIVE WHO BECAME THE
VOICE OF A GENERATION.
>> VOICE OF GENERATION, TBD.
>> WITH A POWERFUL MESSAGE.
>> POWERFUL MESSAGE, TBD.
>> AND A RALLYING CRY THAT SPOKE
TO ALL PEOPLE.
>> RALLYING CRY THAT SPEAKS TO
ALL PEOPLE, TBD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> TDB.
>> AV CLUB CALLS IT, A TOUCHING
TRIBUTE TO WHATEVER IT ENDS UP
BEING ABOUT.
AND ROLLING STONE SAYS, IT'S A
DEFINITELY INTO THE ABOUT PAUL
RYAN.
>> WHO'S THAT STATUE OF?
>> THAT'S THE MAN FROM LONG AGO
WHO STOOD UP TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> FACE TBD.
>> LOOKS JUST LIKE HIM.
>> COURAGE, COMPASSION, COUNTRY.
>> TBD.
>> STORY.
STARRING BRADLEY WHITFORD,
PROBABLY.